clickbait thumbnails trigger warnings oh my
welcome back to my channel here folks if you're
watching this video you are either a hardcore fan
or you're a troll or you're kind of both honestly
trolls if you think my team doesn't see you racing
to the comment section within the first 15 minutes
every single time I post Justice spew vitriol
you're lying to yourself we see you and we think
you're very special members of the Abby's kitchen
Community thanks for the ad rev but anyways today
I'm going to be addressing some of the criticism
I sometimes get about my clickbait titles and
thumbnails along with a really important chat
about trigger warnings so let's start there
actually so my husband doesn't really watch my
content but when he has his only commentary is
something like oh my God it must be so exhausting
to have to have all these trigger warnings and
content notes and preemptive disclaimers about
words that you're saying or not saying before
you can actually get into what it is that you need
to talk about like why is everybody so sensitive
and honestly I've always just kind of ignored his
comments because I was like ah yeah typical man
dismissing the lived experience and Trauma of so
many women who've entrusted me in their safe care
then more recently maybe like a year or so ago
I was talking to my younger sister and my sister
is a clinical psychologist and she told me that
trigger warnings on media content may actually
do more harm than good and again at the time I
was like well yeah maybe that's true for your
content or your audience but my peeps need
these trigger warnings like there's so much
toxic content out there in line as the [__] Wild
West out there and I need to protect people but
then I was on vacation this summer trying to like
fake vacation as we do and this article popped up
on my Apple news feed and I was like oh have I
actually caused more harm by trying so hard to
keep you know everybody happy and safe I'm Gonna
Leave a link to the article below though it does
have a paywall but in short this op-ed draws on
recent research suggesting that trigger warnings
have actually little or no benefit in cushioning
the blow of disturbing content and in some cases
they may actually be harmful for survivors of
trauma basically of the researchers found that
trigger warnings increase the extent to which
people see trauma essential to their identity
which can be counter therapeutic because it
encourages avoidance and exacerbates fear the
researchers said that trigger warnings are one of
many examples of ways that we over emphasize how
important trauma should be in our lives and that
this prevents us from moving onwards and upwards
there's also a whole other meta-analysis looking
at trigger warning outcomes that have found that
presenting a trigger warning had actually no
effect on emotional response to negative materials
but in a lot of cases it increased anticipatory
anxiety about the incoming content like people get
their guard up and it's like they're triggered
before they've even consumed the content that
might trigger them it also found that the warnings
either made people want to read the content more
or it had no effect at all generally speaking
though it seemed clear that trigger warnings
aren't actually great so I called them my sister
again and what she said really spoke to me she
said that basically today day it's kind of a bit
of a landmine to explicitly say that you don't
like or you don't use trigger warnings because
then you seem really non-progressive which is
probably why I've kept them in rotation for so
long because as you guys know I'm a sensitive
person so I really try to treat others with
sensitivity as well but my sister basically
said that trigger warnings were encountered to
everything we know about improving mental health
because the more that we avoid something because
of a past memory of it being scary or bad then
the more scary that memory becomes it basically
adds fuel to the fire it also teaches us that
we're weak and fragile or incapable of coping
or growing you know there was actually a comment
on my recent video about my UK trip which got me
thinking about this all over again and this person
said that people with EDS don't have the impulse
control when it comes to weight loss content and
that may be true for some but it also got me
thinking why are we by default thinking that
folks who have struggled with their mental health
are incapable or weak why are we automatically
taking away people's agency by saying no no no
no no I know people like you you can't handle
anything that's scary or hard because when people
hear that they think that's true now I will just
say that of course if you're in the active throes
of an ed then discuss with your team on whether
or not you should be consuming online content at
all never mind nutrition or Wellness content but
eventually we come out of active treatment and
we need to face the world and let's be honest
the whole world talks about weight loss right it
pops up on your for you page it's at the magazines
at the checkout your relatives talk about it
at the dinner table like sure you could leave
the store every time you saw a magazine with
the words keto on the front page and you could
hide in the bathroom every single time you're at a
family gathering but that doesn't support ongoing
recovery we need to eventually build skills to
face this world with confidence so this is where
I bring all of you guys in like we've got options
right I continue adding trigger warnings to all
my videos so for any mention of weight body food
nutrition tips everything I can not have trigger
warnings for anything and people can listen to my
introduction at the start of the video to see what
we're going to be talking about and then you know
of course assume that there will be some nutrition
or Diet talk in most of my videos or I can be
selective where perhaps I don't share trigger
warnings for most things like diet food nutrition
tips weight loss or weight gain but maybe just
for more sensitive discussions like if there are
explicit Pro Ed tips at creators sharing or if
I'm sharing specific weight or measurements the
pause this video right now and let me know in the
comments where if anywhere you think I should draw
the line so that's trigger warnings now I want to
talk about click bait this is such a Hot Topic
in my content creator circles and it's something
that a lot of us get criticism for or struggle
with what to do so clickbait is a controversial
marketing tactic because its job is to entice
someone to click and watch or read the content
but when the content itself is like a complete
mismatch with the title people feel misled or
like they wasted their time so for example if the
title of a magazine article said how to lose 20
pounds in 20 days but the journalists actually
just ended up talking about intermittent fasting
where one random person happened to lose 20 pounds
in 20 days but all the experts they interviewed
said no you can't lose 20 pounds in 20 days yeah
people will be disappointed because they didn't
find out how to lose a pound a day it's also often
criticized for spreading myths or disinformation
because people will often just read the article
title and not the rest of the article and again
often the title lacks contacts or Nuance or the
whole truth so an article titled berberine works
better than chemo could automatically lead
people to stop their chemo to buy berberine
without reading an article that would obviously
suggest that berberine is not better than chemo
unless it's from like a BS blog in which case it's
the wild west so here's the deal with my click
bait yes my team and I use the psychology apology
of clickbait when crafting our titles clickbait
psychology suggests that our brains are primed
for confirmation bias and simplicity there are
literally millions of pieces of content flying
at us every day our brains will automatically
stop and pick up the pieces that are instantly
recognizable uncomplicated and relatable the video
itself is for the context and the complicated
details the title has to be Snappy it has to
deliver a quick message that hints towards the
content within but also be emotion driven and
human because you're human and I am human and this
is how we connect now as an example I got a lot of
criticism about my video title on my UK Vlog which
was originally did I lose too much weight food and
diet while traveling abroad some people criticize
this title for being click bait and while it may
be clicky and it may be baby I don't see it as
being dishonest or the spreading of misinformation
Vlogs are generally A bit chaotic so I talk about
a lot of things in this one but one of the central
themes for me in this video that I felt would be
most useful for my audience was about how to deal
with unintentional weight loss I could have also
titled this like I saw a ghost because I have a
little section where I talk about ghosts I gotta
call this London shopping hall because a little
fashion moment in there but for me this weight
loss angle was what I felt would be most useful
for my audience and if I baited in my followers
with even disorder histories then great they would
be taking away a supportive message that they
really need that weight loss shouldn't always
be celebrated and that it's sometimes an act of
self-care to eat more and try to gain weight and
that is what I try to do with my titles and
content I hope that people realize that it's
really hard to compete with sensationalized diet
culture when one Creator posts a video called this
supplement will make you lose 10 pounds today
and I post a video called this element may help
support weight loss when taken four times a day
in conjunction with a balanced diet and exercise
regimen which are people going to click on the
latter may be full of misinformation whereas at
least my video will deliver the facts but no one
is going to learn those facts if they don't click
we've actually beta tested so many video titles
and found that if we want my supportive science
driven message to get to the people who actually
need it you Gotta Fight Fire with Fire you need
to build Snappy emotion-driven simple titles
and that means you leave the context to the
video itself that said I'm still truthful in my
titles so for example I will ask questions rather
than make absolute statements and my title still
reflects the content within I get that people are
still mad when you click on a title thinking oh
she's finally going to give us some magic bullet
for weight loss and here I am sharing the like not
so sexy science again but these are typically the
kind of people who need the cold hard truth that
most Wellness culture content is BS the bottom
line is that if we as a community want to share
science not pseudo science as broadly as we can
to the people who need to hear it the most we
need to play ball like I'm up against 20 pounds
in 20 days kind of so just just work with me on
this finally let's talk thumbnails so I got some
Flack for my thumbnails particularly if I share
images of bodies or again anything that might be
triggering again the original thumbnail of my UK
Vlog is a really good example on it I wrote I'm
triggered and I had an image of myself looking
kind of distraught and people in the comments
were suggesting that me saying I'm triggered was
making people triggered so I changed it to this
scared me even though honestly I was triggered as
with the bodies this is super interesting because
my team and I talk about this literally every week
on our calls I don't really show body check images
of myself anywhere online so my thumbnails won't
contain images of me personally posing in a bikini
or bra obviously no shame to other creators
who do this but my body is just not really my
business card that said look at the wellness
landscape like even the most anti-diet diet
culture creators build their thumbnails around
their bodies why because we live in a culture up
obsessed with small fit bodies and we see these
bodies and we want to learn from the people behind
them obviously and in a lot of cases this is
not a bad thing like Natasha for example great
content great evidence-based advice I love her
so no judgment from me to other content creators
who use this tactic like gold Glen Coco like
show off that bod you know just not my style so
even though I might not share my own body when
I'm doing the response video I often utilize
the same body check imagery that they use to
bait people in the first place because again
we sometimes need to Fight Fire with Fire And
if the original content is problematic then I
need to attract the same vulnerable audience who
most needs my safe science-minded interpretation
and rebuttal obviously in a perfect world a hot
body wouldn't be a greater indicator of clout
than education and expertise but this is the
world that we live in right now folks and my
team and I have beta tested this so many times
videos without a hot body in the thumbnail tank
videos with a hot body get clicks welcome to
diet culture one-on-one I am not going to be
able to single-handedly change the game and at
the end of the day folks the people who are easily
influenced by clickbait titles and body checks on
thumbnails are typically the ones who can benefit
from my content the most and maybe just maybe it
will attract someone on the brink of change who
will see my content and have something click where
they realize holy [__] this whole dye culture
thing is not serving me and even if it's just that
one person who gets that aha moment that Sparks
their healing journey I think it's kind of worth
annoying a few people because they were hoping
for more diet culture and instead they got womp
womp critique of diet culture and that was a lot
I would love to hear your thoughts on this
conversation I know this is going to get a
little spicy so please let's keep it respectful
and remember if you're a VIP troll I'm watching
you everybody's watching you don't think
your obsession here doesn't go unnoticed
but on that note that is all for today
if you like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment below and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye